for the mystic arts we harness energy
and shape reality
we travel great distances in an instant
there was such a beautiful image on
screen between the marriage of the
visual effects and the gesture were made
you do well we worked with the amazing J
funk he taught us a whole lexicon of
movements which meant that we could cast
these spells and it was really magical
because we were working with cameras it
was a trip but it was it was worth it
because there was staff the visual
effects director saying there will be a
line of light going from this finger to
that finger and then when you see what
they did that all these movements were
drawing a mandala in the air that was 3d
that T psilocybin LSD just a little
honey did you have a superhero moment on
set when you were suddenly like oh wait
I am in a Marvel movie every day but I
remember very precisely when we were
exploring the look of the ancient one
which took a beautiful few weeks it was
wonderful because we had before we
started shooting we tested all sorts of
ideas every idea that we could dream up
we said well let's just look at it let's
feel it sounds like a plan yeah when I
remember thinking okay that's that and
that's gonna look so great in the match
that was a pretty superhero moment when
you start to think about your own mind
hearing full-time
looking for you
you